>>> VERY GD
>> I'M POPPY
WITH US,T OM NOW, A CRUCIAING, T
ECL MASTER SHOULD BETED TOW THO.
S PRESSER  THAT EP
NEEDED.
WHH S  APITE THE G IT IS ALREAD
FILTER TEAM TO LOOK FOY EDS ACK
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL WASUN MAR-
R ALOULD NEVER
TRUMP'S LAWYERS
EXPECTED TO FINDSSD
FIN LASTIG TS G WIWH THEKARAELHE
RIGHT BEFORE T
AND NOTEFULLYT THEY
WHAT THEDNUE.
r: THAT'S RILAST N T
,
THE JUDGE TO
POINT A SPECIAMASTER
FA HERE.MATERIALTH SEIZED AT MO
AND THEYTHFIAM
TION WHENG THEM.THGUIN THE JUDG
SHOULD IMPOSE SOMEON REVIEW THT
TWICE AS MANMENTS  A
SEIZEDHEIAL AT
EE O, AS MANYHAT
GOTTEN FROM THE TRND
LYE
FIIFICATION FOR E INITIAONHIS CL
DIENSITIVE
INFORMATION CONTAINED WITH IDEN
PRESEN WOULDCOAIFORMATION AV
HE MAD PUSUTF E S THAT D  FM
SMEA
BUT HIS LAWYERS NO TGU
PE IS N FORA SPECIAL ,
FILTER TEAM HAS Y DONE
THE D SHOUT BE DDN'T RECEIVE AES
LE TO
JOINING DISC ERAL COUNSEL S
RVHE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATIS.ACK WITH
SO ONE NOTNSE
ON LEAST, HE
IS PICTU THAT THE AGDENCE
EYOK THET  ANDN TH.
SAYING, HE HAVE
THE
THERE, AND WTEE HAEN
THE CLIALS WERR TO THEENAL, IST?
>>ERS SHOCKING
E CHGEE GAVEHEM ALL
BACK, THEY WERE , TO
NO RHER STARTLIN
ADMISSD WYERIS
YOU KNOW
D THAT WAY,
THTHE  T TAGED G UNUSUATHISN'T .
REON T
NCE, AND THIFTER
RAF GUNSISPLAYA BLE BY T L
DER THE DRUGS, THAT'
INAPPRATS NONOTHINRAPH WAG TH
NS IMENT LAID OUT INHE TRUMP'S L
THE --TOEE
THISULCTASE NOULD HAVE DOCUMHISO
POTENTLLGE
CANNONIRECTIY.S NO SURPRIS WOULS
M.
AT DIFFERENCE.
Y'S HEARTHAT PARLA P JUDGEOD ATA
THO BE
G THEIAIFO SPECIAL MASTER,
THE JUDGE DOES TO DO E
THAT.
ADIT IRALLY ORED.
THJUCIDE TO SORT D OVERKWARDSE
INTEREOFIDENEV
OPRTUNITY AND GO AND THE S UGY
RISKSE CASY TOSSING ONIMINALITDY
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS INTO MOVING
RIIFSERVEDL FOR THE  ONEOF THEN
NE
R GOVERNME E
R O RE
D THEY
PROSECUTED?
>>ANCE HERE
THAT THE DUM SAW AT SE
THORTIMAN SOURCES, SPIES, VERY
SECRETS, THIS IS INFORMATION
IT, OR TGUMAOULD BE REALLY DANGS
UHOSARIES FOUNDT ABOU IMA TE KY
, MAYBE WE NEED TO TAKEPS TO DE
HAVECHR LOCKS  HOME.U ULIFSEIF Y
UST
THEY SEE?
IPLE A HERE.WE COULD HAVO ANYT T
MIGHT HAVE BEEN MP
WE'RE  ING
TAKE THE
RISK.
IS A
RULE IT
O GO A APOSS TREGARD.
AS Y
AT
EMOYKING L RANNGLATHS HOME W A I